four years ago Netflix's traffic was
growing at an exponential rate but not
only was the number of subscribers
growing but the actual hours that each
subscriber was using the services was
growing similarly so this created a lot
of complexity the growing traffic the
diversity of all kinds of different
devices the growing amount of back-end
services and in order to create some
flexibility to handle this complexity we
build Zul if you're a fan of
ghostbusters you'll know that Zul is the
gatekeeper and that's exactly what a
dozen netflix Zul handles all the
traffic coming into netflix into AWS and
then primarily its biggest
responsibility is routing that traffic
where it needs to go but it also
provides us monitoring security
resiliency and flexibility for context
Zul sits between the AWS elastic load
balancers and our back-end services so
since it's the highest point of the
traffic coming in we have a very good
place to monitor traffic that's what
that's the kind of monitoring that
provides us as well as alerting and
anomaly detection and then it's also
responsible for security blocking
fraudulent traffic mitigating DDoS
attacks things like that and then
resiliency things like shielding origins
from excess traffic throttling and
finally flexibility with things like
self-serve routing and Canarian clusters
and features like that so we built Zul
using the standard java model it was
built on Tomcat running java servlets
with blocking requests so in a blocking
request cycle request comes in gets a
request thread does a little bit of work
maybe makes a network call blocks when
the network call completes unblocks
finishes whatever worker was doing and
then returns a response and if you want
parallel as
in that kind of paradigm you need to
have two of those things so each one of
these would be a thread and then you
would scale up to as many threads as you
need to handle the concurrent requests
that you want but when we looked at the
continually growing traffic the trends
of growth didn't stop right they kept
getting bigger and bigger
we knew that we already needed to start
thinking about the next version of Zul
so we looked around the landscape of
distributed systems and all the new
hotness was functional reactive non
blocking programming our colleagues and
Netflix were writing bleeding edge
software for this for this new paradigm
things like rx Java or XJS hystrix and
then others in the industry were really
big on event loop servers like Nettie so
the move seemed kind of like a
no-brainer right we're generally a proxy
so we send a request and then a wait for
a response so we should eliminate that
waiting time so we built a very
comprehensive test application and then
we ran some really thorough benchmarks
with that test application and you can
see that it was awesome right 73,000
requests per second that's great so
let's do it unfortunately the results
that we saw in the real world weren't
quite that good it turns out that the
performance between Zul one and Zul two
was roughly the same so you're probably
wondering was it worth it would we do it
again should you do it you do not do it
and the answer is something you've all
probably heard before
it depends there's actually a very long
list of pros and cons as you can imagine
and it's a it's a nuanced decision it's
not it's not that simple so today I'm
going to touch on how we rebuild Zul
using natty and rx Java
what it's been like operating Zul 2.0 in
the real world and finally when you
should go blocking when you should go
non blocking so the first step was
rebuilding Zul as I mentioned Zul
proxies all the traffic coming into AWS
and that traffic is global from all over
the world and it amounts to roughly tens
of billions of requests per day or
hundreds of terabytes transferred per
day our team is fairly small so given
this amount of traffic we like to keep
things as simple as possible and Zul 1.0
had a very simple architecture request
comes in hits a servlet the servlet runs
it through some pre filters it then gets
routed to an Origin blocks waits for a
response comes back hits the post
filters and then responds back to the
client
despite the simple architecture though
Zul has a lot of responsibilities it's
actually doing a lot more stuff than
just waiting for a response from the
origin so this kind of responsibility
and operational complexity was tough to
manage there's three key hotspots for us
first one was latency concurrent
connections the second one and lastly
thread count so in a blocking system if
our origin had even a minor latency
spike it would increase concurrent
connections significantly and then also
the thread count to deal with that kind
of uncertainty from our origins we use
history if you're unfamiliar with
hysterics it's an open source Netflix
framework and it does a lot of stuff but
primarily what we use it for is circuit
breaking so if a request is taking
longer than it should we'll cut it off
and return a reasonable fallback
that gave us some predictability in
terms of handling that latency another
potential scenario is you have a huge
spike in traffic and your concurrent
connections go up and then your thread
count goes up and the solution for that
is is something pretty common
we just throttle connections so at a
certain point once we hit a certain
number of connections we just don't
accept anymore and similarly with
requests if we're getting too many
requests we'll thrala requests and
reject any requests from coming in but
we can only throttle for so long at a
certain point even when we're throttling
our CPU will get maxed out a couple
instances will fall over a couple more
the remaining instances are not taking
way more traffic than they were before
they fall over and it accelerates until
finally Netflix is down and now that
we're international you can panic in
many languages so how can non blocking
help us here well first let's define
what I'm talking about when I say non
blocking non blocking is composed of
three main building blocks
the first one is non blocking i/o
primitives so you need a way to know
when a socket is ready to write to or to
read from without having to wait for it
and that's something that's provided to
you by your operating system generally
so on Linux you would have something
like a poll on BSD you would have KQ in
the JVM there's also niño and you need
those primitives in order to even do non
blocking in the first place once you
have those primitives in place you need
an asynchronous programming model to be
able to handle deferred execution so you
can use things like queues you could use
reactive extensions there's lots of
things you can do but you need some sort
of paradigm to handle that deferred
execution and still have a program that
makes sense and then lastly if you're
building a web server you need to put
those two things together and the most
common way to do that is with the event
loop pattern and the king of the event
loop pattern in Java is medi which is
what we used
so if you're unfamiliar with what an
event loop is it looks roughly like this
at least in a webserver it would look
roughly like this you'd get a request it
would get queued up and then scheduled
on to the event loop when the event loop
is ready it'll pick up that request do
some work maybe make a blocking call
that block and call would then get or
sorry not blocking call it a network
call in this case there would be non
blocking the network call would get
scheduled eventually it would return the
call back would then get scheduled in
the event loop comes back and then you
respond back to your your caller
so despite making light of the decision
to go in on blocking there are actually
some really strong benefits and for us
the two main ones were performance and
resiliency and our goal was to get
performance by increasing CPU
utilization and then get resiliency by
decoupling connections from requests
however we needed to embark on this
journey in an incremental fashion we
were still running Zul one and it was
taking a ton of traffic so we needed to
incrementally move this thing forward
it's kind of like changing out the
engine of your car while it's driving
down the highway so we call this middle
phase Azul one point five the first step
was switching Tomcat to the APR
connector and you can think of the APR
connector as just like a little event
loop server that runs in front of your
Tomcat instance and decouples
connections from requests and this is
mainly just a configuration change so it
didn't require any coding but it got us
a little bit of that resiliency game and
then the big chunk of work was changing
the way our filter chain worked so
instead of having synchronous filters we
have to create an asynchronous filter
chain part of the reason we wanted this
asynchronous filter chain is so that we
could run the same code in Tomcat and
nettie once we had this asynchronous
core we could execute it in either
container
and in order to do that we have to
change the interface from essentially
from an applied to an apply sink so
instead of returning an actual result it
would return an observable of that
result and then once we put those two
things together we ended up with this
really elegant observable filter chain
where a request comes in it gets mapped
through all the filters and then writes
a response out if there's an error we'll
write an error response and then on
every event we collect some metrics and
this is actually very similar to what
the code in Zul 2 looks like this is
made a little bit pretty but it's very
close so shipping Zul 1.5 gave us some
confidence that we could do this
incrementally and it set the stage for
us moving to Nettie's swapping out the
tomcat container for the neti container
now if you're not familiar with Nettie
I've overlaid Nettie nomenclature on top
of the event loop diagram that I showed
previously so in Eddie instead of having
a queue you would have a channel and you
can take of channel there's one to one
with connections so you would get a
channel queued up the channel will get a
read event the read event gets scheduled
onto the event loop does some work
writes a request out to an outbound
proxy channel reads that response when
it comes back and then sends out the
response back to the client so this is
this is exactly what Nettie does and
important to note this is all running on
a single thread so if you have four
cores you have four event loops so you
would preferably want to run one event
loop per thread the first step in the
netting migration was creating adapters
so we had to adapt our existing rx Java
filter chain and vanetti asynchronous
framework and this is a non-trivial task
you essentially have to send Nettie
events through your observable chain as
observables so instead of sending a byte
buff you would send an observable of
byte buff and you would
have to handle that content properly
which is particularly difficult if you
want to maintain the exact same
functionality and the exact same metrics
as you have in Tomcat and then the next
big step was rewriting the proxy client
so we can no longer block so we can't
use our existing Netflix blocking client
we had to write a brand new nettie
client to do the proxying and we had to
do all that while maintaining all the
same load balancing algorithms that we
had before but once that was done we
ended up with something that looks like
this
this is Zul 2.0 it looks fairly similar
but the difference is we have an Eddy
server fronting the request and we have
an Eddy client behind the requests and
sandwich between those two is the RX
Java filter chain so we're essentially
stitching a nettie incoming request
running it through some rxjava filters
creating a separate neti outbound
requests and then stitching the response
back through that same observable chain
so before we could deploy we ran into a
bunch of issues the first of which was
underlying assumptions made by our
dependent libraries the biggest one was
blocking a lot of our platform code
that's shared across the Netflix is
built with the assumption that we're
running in Tomcat so it's built with the
assumption that requests block so if
you're on a thread you can block that
thread and you're only gonna affect that
request and it's not a big deal and you
do whatever work you need to do and then
you move on
unfortunately with Nettie you can't do
that if you block and Nettie event loop
thread you're potentially pausing
hundreds of requests at the same time so
you can never ever block a Nettie thread
luckily for us there was a great
framework called reactive audit that
actually detected blocking at runtime
and sent us reports to let us know what
was happening and essentially just
throws a stacked
so it looks something like this you can
see we have an underlying library that's
calling thread dot sleep and it just
found it for us the alternative to this
would have been actually digging through
every piece of code and trying to find
some scenario where it might be blogging
so this was this was extremely useful
because we have hundreds of dependencies
that we pull in from other teams another
underlying assumption was thread locals
so again if you're assuming that you're
always going to be on the same thread
for the entirety of the request you can
actually set some state on that thread
and then a different library can pull
that state out and use it for its own
execution you can't do that in Eddy if
you set some state on a thread there
could be hundreds of requests that are
pulling that same state and if hundreds
of requests are setting and pulling the
same state it's basically useless it's
basically random so there was no great
tool for this unfortunately and we had
to do as much kind of manual inspection
and or trial and error to figure out
these kind of problems and as you'll see
later on we couldn't quite get all of
them another concern was was debugging
asynchronous requests so debugging
asynchronous code is just hard like it
just is it's it's much it's much harder
than debugging straightforward blocking
code tracing request failures is really
difficult comprehending stack traces
again they're not particularly useful or
thread dumps right thread dumps are
basically useless and another big
challenge we have is timing these
requests so we had to essentially create
a mapping of state changes and for that
we something inspired by Zach Hellman
who gave a talk on this at last year's
strange loop and it's called the request
passport so what we do is we set this
passport on the channel which is the
connection that's incoming and whenever
we change state whatever
Qwest changes state to you know doing
one thing doing another thing we set
that state and we set a time stamp and
then me when something failed or there's
an error or we just want to debug
something we can make these available so
that we can trace exactly what happened
in this failing request so an example
looks something like this we had an
issue where an ELB was timing out which
is unexpected because our timeouts on
Zul are much lower than the ELB time out
so we weren't quite sure why this is
happening and then we looked at this
passport example you can see the
highlighted lines the request comes in
the client channel becomes active which
means we're making an outbound request
to the origin the client Channel closes
with a read time out 45 seconds later
becomes active again and then about
another 15 seconds or so later the
server channel closes which means the
ELB is now closed that connection and
another 30 seconds or so later the
client channel again becomes inactive
with a retie map so what's happening
here is we're making a request its
timing out we're retrying that request
and before the retry can even get
halfway through the ELB is closing the
connection and it's pretty clear to see
in this timeline right but if we were to
trace this just using logs or stack
traces it would be impossible it would
be especially it would the amount of
traffic coming in it would be very very
difficult to trace these kind of errors
so this this request passport is
essential to debugging any sort of
request failure and we're super happy
with with how much easier is made our
life so once we got past the initial
slew of issues we went to production and
as you can guess there were some long
tail problems the first and kind of most
enduring one was direct memory leaks
so unlike Tomcat Neddie uses direct
memory to do its processing since its
using a pole it's actually running with
J&I bindings it's running at a very low
level so it's it's not allocated on the
heap it's allocating direct memory and
which means you have to free that direct
memory and if you don't it's never gonna
be freed so what we would see is the
servers would slowly use more memory
over time especially clusters where the
instances wouldn't be recycled very fast
and then quietly they would just stop
serving traffic the RPS would go to zero
they wouldn't complain or anything they
just can't allocate any more memory so
it's done this is extremely difficult to
debug the tooling around direct memory
leak detection and Nettie is just not
great and we found the only thing we
could do is more or less trial and error
we'd look through the code we'd find
something that looked like maybe the
observable chain was breaking here and
we weren't closing the request put into
production okay to fix the leak or no it
didn't fix the leak and then it's back
to the drawing board so that was
unfortunate we still actually have some
of these issues but you know it's one of
those whack-a-mole type of situations
and as I mentioned analyzing async code
is hard and not only are we analyzing
async code for one framework we actually
have two asynchronous frameworks being
integrated so we have our X Java being
integrated with Nettie and those
integration points are extremely complex
and then when things go wrong you get
these beautiful stack traces they look
something like this there's a little bit
of our X and then maybe Nettie soon yeah
there's some Nettie stuff so not not
great not great
so aside from deep stacks being bad
it's just unreadable you can't really
make sense of that exception so we have
to actually modify our logger to be a
little bit smarter
so if we see repeating lines you know if
there's ten or twenty lines that are
just like our X observable all it'll
collapse them all into a single line and
just put a counter at the end of that
and that eliminates a lot of that
repetition that you're seeing and that
really deep call stack in our X and then
the other big thing we did that helped
our performance was we just stopped
filling stack traces and critical code
so if we know we're in a piece of code
that if we're getting hammered at 95%
CPU that code is just going to be
throwing exceptions over and over and
over again we just don't feel any stack
traces we log a line and that's it and
that'll help us degrade much more
gracefully because if you're spending
all your time generating these stack
traces and you're getting hammered by
requests you're just gonna fall over
just can't do anything about it the next
scenario is something we like to call
the Gio shuffle so imagine a request is
coming in to Netflix from San Francisco
and that request gets directed to a CDN
server in Siberia or maybe in India or
Brazil or South Africa it's probably not
optimal if you live in San Francisco you
probably don't want to stream your
content from Siberia so our CDN team was
alerted to location issues people are
being map to the wrong place we're
sending people across the globe for for
no reason what's going on so anybody
have any ideas what happened thoughts no
very close yeah thread locals
so as I mentioned this was a very
difficult issue to debug because a lot
of it happens in our underlying library
is not in our actual code so this
particular call which is a geo lookup
was getting set on a thread and then
basically any other request on that
event loop could pull that geo data so
if your request came in you could get a
signed geo data for a request from
Brazil or from you know Siberia or
whatever and suddenly you're getting a
CDN from Siberia so not optimal the
solution for this was we couldn't
rewrite all those dependent libraries
what we had to do is actually set the
thread locals correctly whenever we
entered the event loop so a neti you
have a channel pipeline where all your
channel handlers get executed and what
every time we enter that channel
pipeline we set the thread locals for
all the code for all the state that
potentially may run on that request and
we essentially copy that from the
channel the other scenario is if we go
into an rx thread and we come back we
also have to do the same thing and copy
the state onto the thread locals this is
annoying but unfortunately something we
just had to do otherwise you see these
kind of horrible shuffling issues but it
wasn't all bad
there were there were a lot of benefits
as well particularly around resiliency
so during a retry storm we continued
serving to hundreds even though we're at
max CPU what is a retry storm retry
storm looks something like this so we
have successful requests coming in and
then we have like a baseline rate of
errors and suddenly there's an error
spiked when this happens there's a retry
storm and the retry storm is actually
significantly higher than the error
spike the reason for this is Netflix
devices are by default
very aggressive at retrying because
during normal watching during normal
operations and everything's fine retries
solve almost every problem if there's a
network issue if your device has having
issues whatever it may be those devices
are set to retry very very aggressively
because it'll just keep things running
very smoothly but when there's an actual
error when there's something happens
where something breaks at Netflix those
devices retry multiple times they send
us error logs and the users probably
tapping the screen over and over so that
kind of thing creates this huge wave of
traffic and this time scale is roughly
10 minutes so this wave of traffic hits
really quickly much faster than we could
potentially auto-scale our cluster in
AWS so again normal CPU usage max CPU
when we were on Zul 1 and the only way
to survive this kind of retry storm was
to throttle very very aggressively so
not only would we throttle the retries
but we would actually throttle a lot of
the regular green successful traffic and
that's just to keep ourselves up just so
we don't go down but what we noticed was
a little - is that we could actually
weather the storm we could continue
serving that green line at the same rate
continue serving all the 200s and
actually serve most of the retries
without throttling the actual
degradation scenario between Tomcat and
Metis in particularly the one in Seoul -
is very different so it was a little -
we can handle way more RPS at max CPU
than we could with Zul one and the
biggest reason for this is latency Zul -
is actually doing a lot less work around
that kind of core connection context
switching although all the stuff that
the event loop improves less thread
contention that kind of stuff that stuff
matters a lot when you're at max CPU and
that's what creates this really smooth
latency breakdown which makes little to
handle that kind of degradation at max
CPU much better so this was a game
changer for us this this kind of
resiliency benefit was massive it
allowed us to shield our back-end
services from these huge storms and we
actually took it a step further if we
notice that our origin is airing or
throttling at a certain rate we just
throw away all the retries so if there's
a retry storm that origin won't even see
it
if it starts throttling at 5% or
whatever the number is all those retries
get tossed away and this has helped a
lot this has helped keep our back hands
up because they generally do a lot more
work than we do right we just kind of
pass the request along they actually do
the you know setting up your playback
session and giving you the right CDN to
go to and like all this stuff for giving
you the right movies to see so if we can
reduce the load on them that's a huge
game changer for us and it can keep them
up when potentially they may not have
been previously the other big benefit is
long live connections so with Neddie we
can scale to tens of thousands of
connections per instance which allows us
to go to millions of concurrent clients
and this is allowed us to implement
WebSockets support which we use for push
notifications and for other new features
that our partner teams can come up with
that implement WebSockets so this was
again a really huge improvement that
allowed us to actually push features
that we wouldn't have been able to push
otherwise and then lastly relaxed
latency constraints so we don't really
care how long a request takes because
it's not going to increase our thread
count and we don't really care how many
concurrent connections we have so our
timeouts don't need to be as strictly
guarded as they had to be in Zul 1 so
our origins and our devices can set
whatever timeout they want within reason
obviously and we don't necessarily need
hystrix anymore because the circuit
breaking again isn't critical the the
latency that that request takes doesn't
really matter because the event will
just move on to the other
quests that are not that are ready to be
you know read or written to get it
blocking so which one is right for you
should you go blocking should you go non
blocking so as I mentioned there was
only roughly a 10 to 20 percent gain in
throughput between Zul 2 and Zul 1 and
these numbers are just to clarify these
numbers are not from benchmarks this is
production numbers so same code running
side-by-side on two servers so the
reason for this is Zul has a lot of
responsibilities and fundamentally Zul
is a CPU bound service so we're not just
sitting there waiting for something to
happen we actually spend most of our
time in CPU not waiting for IO and you
can see some of the things on there like
authentication encryption and decryption
hashing there's there's some stuff in
there that's actually very
computationally expensive when you have
to do it for every single request and
response going in and out
so although we improved stuff like you
know context switching and handling
connections better and less thread pools
and all kinds of efficiency the amount
of work that each request takes didn't
actually change right we improved the
stuff around the edges but the core
functionality didn't get any smaller and
that's essentially why the performance
was roughly the same so if you're a CPU
bound service if you have highly CPU
bound workloads you probably don't need
to go non-blocking
it probably won't benefit you that much
and then you'll get other benefits
you'll have simpler operational model
you have way simpler development model
everything is gonna be linear and
particularly if you're running legacy
systems that are already blocking you
may not get any it may not be worthwhile
to rewrite those to be non-blocking
however if you're highly i/o bound you
should definitely go a non-blocking if
you send up a request and then don't
touch the CPU until that request comes
back you are i/o bound you should
probably go non-blocking if you have
long requests or large files where you
may have tons of connections coming in
and just waiting and streaming data you
should probably go in on blocking if
you're reading from a queue at your own
pace you should definitely go in on
blocking if you have massive amounts of
connections concurrently things like
chat room or WebSockets something like
that you should definitely go
non-blocking so some other things to
keep in mind
benchmark accuracy is important I know I
made a joke about it before but that
joke kind of stems from some amount of
reality right it's important to set up
realistic benchmarks so you set your
expectations correctly and you have to
simulate real-world workloads when
you're testing out these new frameworks
right so deciding when to go blocking or
not blocking
again it's not a trivial decision you
should actually verify that these
assumptions that I'm telling you right
now are correct you should run it
against your actual service because
every service is different and then you
have to account for the long-term costs
so going non-blocking has costs
associated with it as I mentioned
particularly apps are harder to debug
there's an ongoing maintenance of async
code that's more difficult than non
async code and then a support and
operations burden and ultimately you
need to ask yourself what critical
features do you really need are those
features worth the costs and what's your
answer to it depends if your answer to
it depends is I want to use this cool
shiny new tech then maybe you should
reconsider maybe you should run some
benchmarks maybe you should verify that
that shiny new tech is actually worth
those costs
so we jumped head in we learned some
hard lessons we learned that our code
base is more complicated than it was
before
we saw some memory leaks we had that geo
shuffle incident you know there's lots
of underlying assumptions from our
libraries that we have to work around
and handle we have to increase the debug
ability with the request passport but we
got huge resiliency gains we're now able
to ship features that we wouldn't have
been able to ship before with WebSockets
and we could configure our timeouts and
create flexibility for our partners so
for us it was definitely worth it and
for you if you decide to use Zul to in
the future and your service is i/o bound
unlike ours you could see some huge
benefits compared to Zul one thank you
[Applause]